but are the negatives to a hysterectomy? Well, again, it depends case by case, so if you're
going to do a complete hysterectomy and have your ovaries removed too, then if your postmenopausal
already one would argue you're not really using your ovaries, they're not really producing much
estrogen and progesterone at that time. Well, that is partially true. Your ovaries still will produce
some estrogen and progesterone, but if you're just recently metapausal or if you're not metapausal,
yet then you will basically put yourself into the metapaus by having your ovaries removed.
Negatives to removing the uterus are less, there's less negatives as far as, you know,
there obviously there's eye negatives like I mentioned, you could have issues with tipped
bladders and then pooled of urine in the bladder and recurrent bladder infections. That's something
that can be helped out not completely corrected by doing some different manipulation to the pelvis
and manipulation to the bladder. If you find, you know, a good practitioner,
other than that, there's not, you know, horrible growth negatives to getting your uterus removed.
So, you know, we've had clients that have had uterine cancer that was contained in the uterus,
but they did not want to have their uterus removed for whatever reasons. They were afraid of surgery
and such. And, you know, every case is different. Many times we had to kind of talk people into
getting over that fear because many times if you can debug a cancer, you can, in certain cancers,
it can be, it can help tremendously. So, there's not these, there's not huge negatives. Some people
would argue the same thing with, I've seen posts up there about appendix ways you can heal appendicitis
naturally. I think that's just, there's, it's kind of foolish, you know, you deal with possible infection
that could spread and kill a person. I just don't think we need to be so afraid of the, you know,
medical care even though there's lots of negatives to tenders of care these days. We don't want to
just clump everything into that negative bucket even though many things deserve to be clumped into
that bucket. But you have to use wisdom. That's what we're called to use. And if, if the circumstances
are the case, um, prevail to push us through all the wisdom that we can, that that would be the best
mode of action than we should take the best, best mode of action. And I think through prayer
and through asking questions, so ask questions of people like me and other people that have had
patients that have done hysterectomase, really we haven't seen issues with it. Of course,
you do the complete hysterectory removing the organs and you're not in menopause, you're going to
put yourself in menopause. If that's the case, then you really want to support your adrenals because
your adrenals do make progesterone and adjust in estrogen to a lesser extent. And people that go
through menopause, um, you know, sail through menopause without too many menopausal symptoms are
people that have really healthy adrenal glands. People that already have fatigue of their adrenal
glands, they're the ones that go through menopause and have tons of hot flashes and tons of symptoms
because of that drop in, in rebound of estrogen and progesterone that's sudden when the ovary
starts to shut down. People with really healthy adrenal glands don't really notice that because
their adrenals are making up for it. So, um, yeah, there's positive negatives to any surgery too. So,
I don't want to make it sound like it's easy, but if you if you're discussed it with multiple
different surgeons, discuss it with other doctors and you're, you know, doing, you know, some study,
you know, looking at positives and negatives on the internet, um, don't be scared of it. And then
you're taking it to prayer and you're deciding what's the best course of action for my case.